hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game with a lot of twists from the
2018 World Rally Championship for women
it's again between Grand Master Zhu
engine and Grandmaster Caz renal Agno
now it's always interesting when I when
I watch the the official broadcast
meters mischenko always calls it the the
women's section in the open section even
though there are no women playing in the
open section so it basically is the
women's section in the men's section but
yeah I have no idea a lot of people have
asked me this why holy fun is not
playing I really don't know maybe maybe
she's just caught up in her studies or
not not really sure one of the games
that I was hoping to show you it's also
from this women's section is animals
each overseas Jew in June but their game
was a well a pretty equal trade off and
they quickly went into a rooks end game
which was equal and then animals took
just blundered the game buddy I was very
very looking forward to that one as Anna
did not play in the previous World rapid
embolus championship due to her protests
and well jus in June 1 in the 2017
world's rapid championship so she is the
defending champion but yeah I was I will
put a link to that him in the
description below if you if you just
want to check it out but yeah here she
faces Catarina Logano and she opens with
d4 and I would just like to thank
everyone for sending me so many photos
and videos for the 2019 subscribers
video it's really gonna be awesome if
you if you have any ideas in any ways to
improve it also there is an email in the
description below so you know aside from
the photos and videos feel free to send
me your suggestions as well d 6 we have
night or three night to have six the
indian game g3 and g6 brush-up the g2
but of the g7 and they both castles so
now everything is set a nice symmetrical
position we can start the game rook to
e1 Knight B to d7 are going for a 5 dead
central a thrust
efore and E 5 and this is a pretty
standard position it was reached many
times in between a lot of different
players I think
this efore even there's a game between
guru shocking Kramnik which ended in a
draw
e5 Knight to c3 c6 and now comes a four
rook to e8 black simply develops h3 went
to c7 and now comes a five and this is
still a position that was reached plenty
of times amongst many players he
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 and
now comes Knight to c5 putting pressure
against that e4 pawn bishop to f4 and
excellent score for the bishop and this
is why maybe it's it's such a wonderful
position that was also reached many
times before and every time this Bishop
to f4 is played pinning this d6 pawn you
don't want to allow this at this x-ray
between the bishop and the Queen and
nice to h5 this was played in this game
but it was also played in every other
game where Bishop to f4 was played not
in perhaps not every other but in in a
lot of games there was a a most notable
game is between Alexander zoobel and GU
shaman from the 2016 Sun wastages
tournament where this exact same
sequence of moves was used and of course
you want to kick that bishop away you
don't want to allow it to stay there it
can either maybe go III C 1 D 2 maybe
even g5 but not really so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find why
it doesn't work it's basically a blunder
this Knight to h5 move but everyone
always plays it but feel free to pause
the video and find out why it wasn't
played for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are once again
an excellent exploiter of Knight and the
rim moves and for us we just want to
enjoy the show
Knight d2 b5 what what a nice idea so
what's uh what's the the idea behind it
can you just pick up this Knight
well not really if you play C capture
some b5 then okay you are up a piece for
the moment but then you face a Bishop
captures on d6
simply grabbing the pawn attacking the
Queen the Queen has to move and also you
just removed the defender of the
of the c5 Knight once the Queen moves
you're just gonna grab it and there's
really no way for you to keep on
protecting the night if you go something
like Queen to c6 then you get a five
again it's an open attack against the
Queen the Queen has to move and only
then will you pick up the knight back
and white will simply have a winning
position but in this game like in the
game between Zubov and shopping after
this Knight d2 b5 we have Queen to d7
and now comes Bishop captures on d6 it's
interesting in the
Zubov game this was played as well even
though the engine prefers and Knight
captures on d6 because after Knight
captures on d6 the rook is under attack
but now you have to go into Knight
captures pawn captures rook to f8
getting the rock out of the way and now
e5 you have this monster night on d6 but
it seems that whoever played with the
white pieces when they got to this
position they it was they weren't
prepared for it black just blundered
with this knife to h5 move oh okay
Bishop to d6 is played here we have nice
to e6 getting in the night out of the
way as the pawn is no longer protecting
it and now Knight 283 Juve engine
continues in the same fashion acts as
Alexander's uber in 2016 and here we
have Bishop to d4 again the same exact
move show being played in 2016 which
simply doesn't work and we have Knights
the c4 now and blacks position is just
terrible here there are the biggest
problem is with the dark square
weaknesses you don't really know what to
do with your Bishop if you if you trade
it for the Knights that's just terrible
then you're gonna have a whole lot of
dark square weaknesses with this Bishop
going all the way the Queen can come to
h6 but okay here we have looked to d8
piling up on the D file and here is the
difference between the game
Alexander Zubov plays Queen to d3 here a
Jew engine plays Queen to e to here but
the idea is pretty much the same you are
given this Knight some protection and
also you are preparing to bring this
rook into the game we have Knight to g5
and now comes G for attacking the knight
on h5 also the rook a to d1 immediately
was also a possibility
g4 and it now comes quinta east six a
very interesting move offering this
night on h5 but accepting the nightly -
a very complicating position after pawn
captures on h5 you get you could go
Knight captures on h2 recheck but even
better is getting rid of all of these
guys here Knight captures and now after
Queen captures c5 but now after a five
white will just keep a better position
Queen e7 now comes h4 attacking the
knight now comes Knight h3 check
captures captures and after Queen to e4
attacking the bishop Bishop captures
pawn captures and now after Bishop to f5
white will just retain a better position
with being an exchange up you can go h6
you can completely stifle blacks
position but okay after Queen to e6 a
Jew engine does not go for this line a
rather Bishop to h2 this Bishop is an
extremely powerful piece she wants to
play e5 and create a really a powerful
powerful central control Knight to g7
now there are no tricks you have to put
the knight back and now comes look a to
d1 h5 here black wants to start an
attack but now comes h4 kicking the
night away nine eight seven and now g5
and now it's really gonna be a problem
to get this Knight back into the game
Queen to e7
perhaps with ideas of sacrificing on g5
but also preparing to bring this Bishop
into the into the game be five and now
comes Bishop to g4 attacking the Queen
Bishop to f3 blocking Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Knight to f5
attacking the h4 pawn and here Queen to
f4 was played and this move actually
allowed Katarina to bounce back into the
game
Bishop to g3 was the the correct reply
defending this pawn with the bishop but
you have to put your bishop here so so
white can capture it but here after
Bishop captures Queen captures on c3
Knight captures and g3 Queen captures
and g3
rook captures and e1 rook captures rook
to d8 you would still get this nice the
d6 move where white would be what would
be much better in the game this pawn is
protected by playing Queen to f4
but here Katrina does not continue with
the best move she played bushel captures
on c3 immediately but the proper defense
is actually Queen to be for attacking
the c4 Knight and only after Knight to
d6 is played now you play Bishop
captures on c4 and c3 and now white
cannot trade Queens on before and nor
does white even one or trade Queens
because you would capture back with the
bishop you would have to capture back
and then after captures you would have
to capture the bishop and then you still
lose the edge for pawn and now even
though White has a better position it's
hard to say if if white can actually
force this into a win so this was the
the one moment in the game where after
that night to h5 mistake in the
beginning Katarina really had a chance
to bounce back but after Queen to f4
Bishop captures on c3 was played we have
B captures and now we have an exchange
here rook captures rook captures rook to
d8 and now not exchanging in the final
pair of rooks but tonight's to d6 now
and okay
Queen to e6 we have rook to be free and
now comes Knight captures and e6 pawn
captures and e6 black had to make these
exchanges to try and bring the knight
back into the game night to f8 and now
comes look to e3 attacking the Queen
Queen to d5 and now comes Queen to f6
and here as you can see it is very very
difficult for black Bishop to e5 is the
threat and this will result in Queen to
g7 checkmate
it doesn't matter nice to e6 can't come
to defend but you can always simply
remove the defender by capturing the
night with the rook
so here black tried a series of checks
rook to d1 check King g2 Queen to d5
check King to f1 now okay if you go back
to the 1yf can simply block with the
rooks Oh Queen to c4 check we have King
to g1 and now comes Queen to g4 check
Bishop to g3 and now roof to d7 and okay
now there's no danger of Bishop to e5
since the bishop is pinned but there is
another very nice move for white
I feel free to pause the video here it's
a force to checkmate in seven with best
defense but only the first move is
relevant so feel free to do it I will
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just found a
very nice
checkmate in seven and for those of you
who just won't enjoy the show
rook to e8 a wonderful move that
whatever black does and stare ibly for
black and there's no way around it let's
say you just play a silly move it's a
place C 5 just so you know what the
threat is Rock chapters on f8 is the
threat King chapters Queen - h8 this
will be checkmate as the pawn is
controlling the e7 square but in the
game of course Katarina saw that this
was not possible so she tried Queen d1
check but after King 2h - there are no
more checks so there's no point in
trying anything here you're just gonna
you're just gonna lose the lose the game
you can eliminate this pawn because the
bishop also controls this so there is no
move to make you if you can I said it's
an 18-7 because you can now start you
know playing silly moves but it's really
just a force force resigning - so that's
the game I really do hope you enjoyed
it's really a wonderful game and
especially since there were so many
games up until that position where
Bishop to f4 was met with Knight to h5
really I mean such a such an exciting
move you know to happen so many times
and every time white counter that would
neither D to b5
so if this happens to you you know just
gonna ID b5 you're gonna win a very nice
game but yeah just so I don't forget
these are the standings after 12 rounds
as the women only played 12 rounds not
15 it was 4 rounds per day
Julian June won first place as you can
see with with 10 points the only one
would stand out of 12 then we have a
couple of them with 9 and then you have
Onimusha took with with 8 and a half she
lost to do engine so if she hadn't
perhaps yeah I mean if she won against
you of engine perhaps she would now be
on a nine and a half and would have won
this tournament but Julian defends her
title from 2017 and is now again the
2018 Women's rapid world champion so
that's basically it I do hope you
enjoyed that and
get back to some blitz games today hope
I will be able to cover them as their
blitz games you know happening so fast
but yeah like I said feel free to check
out the description below join the
subscribers video 2008 and nineteen it's
really gonna really gonna be a blast
yeah as usual you can check two of my
previous videos your thing called for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more interesting content from the
2018 world lits championship thank you
all and I will see you soon